ABBY CAREY: Hey, Martin.
How's it going?
MARTIN OMANDER: Hey, Abby.
Well, I'm having a European wine
party with a group of friends
soon, and we each want to buy a
vintage wine from a small wine
store in Paris.
The website shows
how many euros it is,
but it doesn't
convert to US dollars.
ABBY CAREY: You know, I
think we could build you
a new tool with Python
that'll save you
and your friends
some conversion time.
I'll show you how.
[THEME MUSIC]
ABBY CAREY: Python is one of
the most popular programming
languages and growing.
It's well suited for
a number of use cases,
including web applications,
machine learning, and big data.
Cloud Run lets you use
any runtime you want,
making it easy to deploy
Python in a serverless way.
Cloud Run is also
fully managed, meaning
you don't have to worry
about infrastructure scaling
if your service starts
getting a ton of traffic.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds awesome.
Do I have to change
my Python code
to get it to run on Cloud Run?
ABBY CAREY: If you have an
existing stateless Python app,
all you need to do is
add one file to deploy
a surface to Cloud Run.
No code changes needed.
We like to use Flask
for small services
like this because it's a
lightweight framework that's
easy to set up.
Our service has
the basics, an HTML
file where we create a form to
get user input, a simple CSS
file, and an app.py
file where we set routes
and define functions.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
That looks exactly like the
web apps I've built before.
What is that extra file
I need for Cloud Run?
ABBY CAREY: The last
file we need to define
is the Docker file.
This allows us to customize
the runtime of our container
to suit our needs exactly.
Containers are a way to
isolate our application
to make it run the same no
matter where it's deployed.
When creating a
Docker file, we first
need to specify a base Docker
image with the front command.
This is where we set
our Python runtime.
The copy command adds files
from your Docker client's
current directory.
The run command installs
Flask, gunicorn, and currency
converter dependencies
for our service.
And finally, CMD is a command
to start our application
inside the container
and binds it to a port.
The app app at the end
means import our app
from the app.py file.
MARTIN OMANDER: What
if I want to use
a different version of Python?
ABBY CAREY: One of the
advantages of Cloud Run
is that you can run
any Python version you
want as long as there is a base
Docker image available for it.
I can even use the newest
version of Python, version 3.8,
if I want to.
Now that we have
our Docker file,
we can build our container
with Cloud Build.
This bundles up our code
along with everything
we've added in our
Docker file and pushes it
to the Container
Registry, a place
to store container images.
And finally, we deploy
the service to Cloud Run.
It only takes two commands
to get the service out
to the world.
In our terminal, we
first build the container
using the builds command.
And then we deploy the
service using the container
image we just built.
If we check out the Cloud
Run section of Google Cloud
console, we now see
our Cloud Run service.
If we click the
service, we can see
important info, like metrics
and the URL of our service.
We can also redirect
or split user traffic
to previous revisions if
we discover our latest
revision has a breaking change.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
This sounds great.
Let me test it out.
Oh, wait.
I think I'm doing
something wrong.
I'm being taken
to an error page.
How can I find out
what's going on?
ABBY CAREY: That's where Cloud
Monitoring comes to the rescue.
Everything that happens
within this service
is logged in Cloud
Monitoring, including errors.
You can see the
logs of our service
from the Cloud
Monitoring-powered Logs tab.
I think this is showing a
little too much info though.
If I had to the
Metrics tab, I can
see the latest errors filtering
out all the other noise.
Let's take a look.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm.
Looks like an error value
was triggered on line 20.
ABBY CAREY: Ah!
I didn't account for
submitting an empty string.
Let's fix that, build,
and deploy one more time.
Ah.
That should do the trick.
MARTIN OMANDER: Awesome.
Looks like it's now working.
Let me see how much this
wine is going to cost me.
Oh, I think I need to
take some money out
of my savings account.
ABBY CAREY: Oh, no.
I'm sure it'll be
worth it, though.
MARTIN OMANDER: But,
anyways, thanks.
I can't wait to share this
service with my friends.
I think it'll come in handy.
ABBY CAREY: If you want to check
out the code for this video,
look in the description below.
Until next time.
[THEME MUSIC]